êtes vous choqué par la différence d'âge
dans les comptes alors on a des témoins
qui sont venus nous voir et on a tout
d'abord on à jane jane vous avez 65 ans
vous êtes magnifique merci beaucoup
d'être très jolie vous êtes assistante
ressources humaines et animatrice radio
et comédienne vous avez deux enfants de
quarante deux ans 38 ans cinq
petits-enfants
vous avez été élue miss cougar en 2011
tout à fait poignarder france la wii a
précisé miss cougar c'est quoi c'est en
fait c'est la miss cougar miss cougar tu
sais quoi comment bien miss cougar ses
jours voilà c'est vous vous aimez sortir
avec des garçons beaucoup plus jeune
voilà donc quand on m'a proposé
l'élection de miss cougar je me suis
déjà posé la question si j'étais une
cougar alors ben oui je me suis rendu
compte que j'en étais une fille
indépendante une grande différence danse
avec les hommes avec qui je suis sorti
alors votre mari est votre votre mari
mais je dois vous avez eu deux enfants
la personnalité vous avez eu deux
enfants il avait votre âge ou pas il
avait votre âge ou pas oui à peu près
voilà et après c'était quand je suis
parti voilà j'ai au bout de 30 ans de
mariage
quel âge oh là là j'ai un problème avec
la je devais avoir 55 ans à contretemps
et à 55 ans vous sortir avec des garçons
de calage après après je suis ce temps
des chiens des jours qu'elle adore je
suis en train de chercher justement elle
avait 21 ans on avoir dominé non
seulement je leur dirai 30 ans j'ai à
peu près 30 ans donc 25 ans à baltanas
et aujourd'hui vous êtes en couple non
je suis pas en couple est la dernière
personne avec qui vous avez une âme on
tient les 30 1 y avait 30 ans voilà le
genre de votre fils quoi c'est le cas du
jeune alors quand il était plus jeune
que son fils exactement qu'est pourquoi
pourquoi vous choisissez des hommes
beaucoup plus jeunes c'est à dire que
les personnes qui sont de mon âge entre
guillemets je ne les vois pas je ne
mange c'est le regard qui flashent yann
moix que passer leurs gammes au clash
donc c'est vrai que je rencontre
quelqu'un qui est beaucoup plus jeune
ça c'est avec un regard j'aime j'aime le
dynamisme j'aime la joie de vivre j'aime
que quelqu'un soit comme moi en france à
donner mais il ya des personnes de votre
âge qui est qu'ils ont du dynamisme qui
ont la joie de vivre non vous en trouvez
pas bah non
j'accroche pas un regard ah oui pourquoi
pas écouté demandez à mes yeux un ancien
soldat qui n'accroche pas du tout je
retrouvais pas dans le regard de l'autre
je les vois pas même en gardant eric
revel
non c'est comme ça le chaudron de
réfléchir parce que alors non mais c'est
jane juste prix donc vous vous vous
n'arrivez pas concevoir de sortir avec
un homme de plus de combien matt 55 ans
55 ans c'est impossible c'est à dire
qu'après j'ai constaté que vous c'est
quoi ces voies plus la personne est
transsexuel c'est une question voilà je
ne vois plus la personne en tant que re
sensualité et sexualité
ouais dynamisme comme moi je le conçois
je sais ce que je crois qu'ils
comprennent des munitions ça comme si
j'avais eu mon lot mais eric naulleau
vous vous dites non à vous la vie bien
rangée l'ajout choque pas je peux pas je
peux pas adhérer à ce discours parce que
je n'ai absolument pas le sens de l'âge
mais dans la vie c'est à dire pardon de
l'amitié il ya des gens qui sont amis
avec des gens de leur âge
moi je pourrais très amis et
complètement oublié que les personnes à
30 ans de moins que moi ou 30 ans de
plus c'est moi je suis au père pote avec
le père fouras question c'est une
question de regard je n'accroche pas
mais voilà si non c'est pas vrai vous
vous êtes fait une catégorie et
maintenant vous projeter sur cette
catégorie ce que ça peut pas passer que
par le regard si vous aviez manqué par
l'âge alors j'y vis mohamed vous êtes le
seul choqué par ladite nous pourquoi je
suis seul sincère surtout on va faire
les hypocrites parfois ça peut être
choquant alors je suis pas un
psychopathe de là je peux vous dire
qu'au bout de deux ans et demi je
commence à être choqué néanmoins lorsque
l'écart se creuse sur l'instant je pense
que ça peut être sympa 50 ans 30 ans
pourquoi pas mais plus on avance dans
l'âge plus dans le temps et plus la
dépendance peut arriver et l'écart
devient monumentale et j'ai vu des
personnes âgées de 80 ans avec quelqu'un
de 60 ans les personnes de 60 ans
devient l'aidant principal
elle l'est plus les poules il épouse
mais simplement une auxiliaire dé
je pense qu'à partir du moment où on
accepte ça qu'on accepterait
l'auxiliaire on peut accepter cette
relation mais faut pas être hypocrite
imaginez simplement un dîner à gâteaux
de prouvent les ibis à écouter du goût
bas eric revel ou un autre alors il va
aller voir chantal goya chanter du booba
également bons ballons
ça va ma position mais oui vous vous
vous dites moi j'ai une femme qui a dix
ans de moins que moi ça va disant non
mais là ça va mais je pense que la
société est beaucoup plus dur avec les
femmes qui sont plus âgés
ça se regarde le un fait de l'or que
leurs compagnons que le contraire
juste parce que dans l'autre sens on se
dit le type il ay là il a réussi à
embarquer à des lords a épousé une femme
plus jeune
alors c'est plutôt les récits richmond
série permettre de faire l'avocat du
diable il ya aussi des grande différence
d'âge entre hommes et femmes et a
souvent des mecs qui disent ou des
femmes qui disent ouais ils ont 25 ans
d'écart c'est un peu le pigeon elle se
meut vécu parce que il ay la de
l'oseille tu sens on en a on l'a entendu
ou le contraire ya des mecs qui disent
non mais on entend aussi des mecs très
jeunes qui souhaitent avec des passagers
en mai 2006 mais avec des femmes plus
âgées et on dit voilà il s'est mis avec
elle parce qu'elle avait beaucoup
d'argent et qu'il a envie d'être
entretenue ça ça marche dans les deux
sens après les deux sources ça marche un
bon groupe band hero l'agencé comme ce à
quoi la plupart des relations c'est
comme ça quand vous voyez quelqu'un qui
va qui va se mettre en couple avec une
personne de 60 ans comme c'est pour ses
beaux yeux mais joie yoplait pour
l'oseille
non mais vous voyez c'est alors attendez
c'est ce que se disent les gens leur
mejdina confejes que maze il a 21 ans et
il est chargé d'assistance en assurance
et vous avez une relation avec une femme
de 53 ans vous en aviez 18 et vous avez
été dégoûté alors bas vous souhaiter
pour l'oseille
bah ouais ben un petit peu non il faut
dire que je vais être honnête
ouais vous êtes vous êtes contraint away
clairement ouais donc alors on sortir
avec ma grand mère j'ai pas le temps moi
d'accord non mais là non plus moi
j'arrive pas non plus à la déconfiture à
faire son avis sur table avec un
personnel ou c'est d'abord d'habana
général d'abord non mais déjà il n'aime
pas généralement à braila son analyse et
son expérience personnelle a fait que
c'est une mauvaise expérience hors
caisse qui est pas si vous êtes sorti
avec une vague de cinquante trois ans ça
s'est passé comment et ben en fait
j'avais rencontré normalement voir tout
ça alors oui en extérieur donc un onni
d'extérieur et j'avais trouvé mais que
j'avais se trouvait jamais coûte est
enfin tombée ce côté maternel donc je la
prenais un peu comme une 2e à verbier 18
ans voilà je la prenais un peu comme une
deuxième maman est en fait au final je
me suis aperçue qu'elle avait quelques
rapprochements qui était vicieux
j'appellerais ça c'est à dire elle
commence à me caresser un peu là puis
c'est tout ça non mais vous vous avez
une aventure avec elles n'ont même pas
un an après à parler d'accord bon ça
commence à aller ça a commencé comme ça
et après donc je suis parti chez elle je
pars tu manges et tout ça on s'est posé
son canapé ouais et là bas c'est parti
quoi
[Rires]
la forme pour votre merci tout
maigrichons comme vous êtes vous n'avez
pas pu vous défendre elle avait beaucoup
de griche non non vous étiez vous étiez
consentants maintenant je l'avais fait
en temps voilà vous êtes sous dos
qu'elle vous a plu sur le nom quoi vous
avait été calé enlever ses vêtements
voire à pendouiller un peu trop l'a
arrêté lé voix contre trois en manif oui
non mais quand à laver ses vêtements
c'est vrai qu'elle était belle les mêmes
vêtements non non non elle laissait pas
bien conservée pour son avec wwa est
donc et vous avez vous êtes à savoir
maintenant de leicester est resté
combien de temps avec elle un
d'apprécier combien dans lesquelles ça
va pas durer trois semaines
au bout de trois semaines je suis avec
elle quoi au bout de trois semaines et
une fois que vous avez couché là qu'elle
voulait plus revu en terminant quoi ça
vous avez non j'ai même que j'ai même
pas couché pendant six mois après à huy
vous imaginez pas cyril laparre la peau
elle peut nous nous sommes arrêtés
respect ça change quoi vous dire moi je
vais vous dire que mes 50 ans cinquante
ans que s'il voulait faire en 50 ans non
mais là là vous êtes dur quand même
non je suis rien vous étiez dur aussi
avant mais non fonctionnels et et vous
verrez de quoi vous avez vous avez été
gentleman avec quelqu'un vous l'avez dit
on vous l'avait dit quoi non je vais
enlever un petit et ça mais je dis que
ça ne ferait pas la finance ben si il
faut bien le dire
elle me vous était alors vous alors je
vous avais bien là vous me décevez
pourquoi ça se fait pas en un mois mais
ont baissé mais ça se fait pas bell a
pris direct un moment donné quand elle a
vu que ça montait plus elle a compris
alors à côté vous il ya stéphane edouard
qui est affligé non mais les fans de
cette sociologue vous avez écrit deux
livres 50 leçons pour séduire et
êtes-vous faits l'un pour l'autre
vous pensez comme au quotidien ou hétéro
binaire de base est forcément berné par
le polyamour parce qu'il croit être un
accès à une sexualité libre déjà et sur
la différence d'âge vous dites quoi
alors sur la différence d'âge déjà le
premier truc mais on a remarqué le même
mot on s'est arrêté sur le mot
consentement ouais mon voisin de droite
aurait été une femme et un homme de 55
ans lui aurait passé la main sur la
cuisse vous auriez le csa au cul chers
amis c'est vraiment et là ça fait rire
tout le monde mais il a raison c'est
vrai il a dit aussi attendre encore
franchement stéphane vraiment
aux membres du csa elle a quitté m6
alors alors oui merci c'est gentil par
rapport à la différence d'âge proprement
dit s'il veut faire de la sociologie
sérieuse dans les quelques secondes que
je vais avoir des deux coupes et il est
sain pour moi il faut faire la
différence entre ce qu'ils fassent une
fois espi récurrent en fait c'est à dire
que quand on a une expérience une fois
et qu'elle est désagréable c'est un
petit peu comme si sur un calendrier de
l'avent on tire un chocolat en disant
bon ce jour-là il est fini on passe à
autre chose
ça m'a permis par le en en étant un peu
écoeuré de quelque chose passer à autre
chose quand quelque chose est récurrent
en par contre au contraire quand c'est
récurrent quand ça se reproduit souvent
c'est en général qu'en fait on n'est pas
arrivé à à passer à la suite donc il ya
un très bon il ya un roman mythique là
dessus qu'ils s'appellent lolita wydadis
eric naulleau laluque beaucoup beaucoup
cité que finalement peu qu'on lui où le
héros explique un petit peu mieux qu'il
ya deux mois que cela fait deux mois
dernier mais c'est la même chose c'est
là qu'en fait ce sont ils focalisent sur
des femmes plus jeunes parce qu'elle
leur échapper à l'âge où il aurait dû et
les avoir donc en réalité c'est l'aveu
d'un échec
c'est je fais plus tard avec mon argent
ce que j'aurais dû faire avant avec un
à-côté mon talent et sa main serré ça
alors je dis lolita d'alizée personnes
d'origine non non surtout pas à sa merci
je suis karim zéribi vous n'êtes pas
choqué par différence d'âge on va voir
ce que noah l'âge d'un couple qui ça
fait longtemps vous êtes ensemble un
lionel et mireille mireille à 70 ans
lionel 44 ans 25 menace pesante
différentes aux mondiaux alors karim
c'est intéressant la sociologie je pense
que ça peut pas résumer tout ce qui se
passe dans la société
donc et ça peut effectivement servir
d'exemple sur des noms mais juste sur le
sur le sujet la wii nommé d'accord mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
pour moi il ya deux deux paramètres qui
sont fondamentaux c'est le consentement
et la sincérité delà de l'amour qui est
qui et qui ressenti entre deux êtres
après je suis pas juge ou procureur pour
décider s'ils ont le droit ou pas d'être
ensemble
si on a deux adultes majeurs consentants
qui ne peuvent plus quitter même s'ils
ont de 20 ans 25 ans d'écart mais qui je
suis moi pour leur expliquer que ça va
bien honnêtement je sais bien connu dans
la société des préjugés et qu'on m'a
expliqué qu'elle est avec lui parce
qu'il ya de l'argent pas quand le
football
elle trouve sa femme est ce qu'on dit
elle est avec lui parce qu'il a de
losail et qu on le dit - et ça passe
beaucoup plus donc
or quand une femme ou un homme on prend
quelqu'un de plus âgé on va aller
chercher des choses
audrey de l'amour comme s'il ne pouvait
passer mais comme si c'était
inimaginable je trouve franchement
présomptueux de dire moi je savais
qu'une femme de mon âge
donc ça fait trente ans que je suis
mariée mais je ne suis personne pour
juger d'un couple la différence d'âge de
leur sincérité ou pas je veux dire un
moment donné faut être ouvert et
tolérant dans la vie si ils s'aiment et
qui sont au rendez nous pourquoi on va
les en empêcher explique alors on a dû
ce moment lionel globale et mireille
qu'ils sont ensemble depuis huit ans
pacsé ou êtes rencontrés sur un site de
rencontres oui on s'est déjà vu un homme
nous deux est donc sûr que le site de
rencontre c'était sursauter baddou un
baddou baddou mano baddou baddou
d'accord alors vous êtes vous dit vous
vous dites victime de racisme à cause de
la différence d'âge parfaitement
voilà pourquoi comment déjà vos familles
ont réagi pour vous à lionel je pense
que notamment pour mais je dis ça va pas
être un scoop nos familles ont mal réagi
ah ouais vraiment mais ont surtout la
vôtre surtout cette de milliers de on va
dire que là il ya une parité et une
équité parfaite d'un côté comme de vrais
un fils qui a quarante trois ans alors
là je me lâche 2 à accepter bien sûr
ouais et me dit quoi
mais on sait plus parler il si vous
aviez m'a dit tu fais ce que tu veux bon
tu fais ce que tu veux ta vie bon mais
moi l'arrêter c'est pareil j'étais enfin
de mariage or quand j'ai rencontré
lionel ça ne l'est plus du tout et mon
mari
et quand j'ai rencontré lionel jeu j'ai
quitté mon mari deux mois près d'accord
si vous allez à remettre ça vous dérange
pas d'avoir mis votre fils de côté à
cause de votre compagnon manon office et
lille et il a sa vie il à sa femme à ses
enfants
s'adapter au monde pas pour nous le
garder il a sa vie à faire c'est de
chair il n'a pas de combat c'est sûr je
n'ai pas de vous êtes ensemble et il l'a
toujours pas accepté non non non la
famille de côté je parle pas de leur
enfance mais il avait attention alors
vous vous ne parlez pas à vous à vos
parents n'ont plus les bah oui mais ils
ont l'âge de mireille si vous voulez
aller par là elle est là la parité je
suis fils de mireille et vont à bordeaux
par an n'a rien ben même pas tu fais ta
vie on se parle pas et ça se fait comme
ce à quoi les gens vous leur avez dit
chouette mireille vous êtes arrivé avec
mireille chez vos parents vous leur avez
dit voilà géant non non non mais rien
n'est jamais allé chez mes parents n'ont
jamais et alors on se côtoie pas voilà
mais pourquoi comment s'est passé vous
les avez tout simplement je pense que il
est mal perçu que mireille et l'orage et
donc par définition j'étais moi j'ai été
mariée pendant dix ans j'ai tant coup
pendant 11 ans avant de connaître
m'irait vous avez laissé tomber votre
sur ces pourris
non non j'ai était divorcé quand j'ai
rencontré mireille et ça a été le coup
de foudre
ben oui puisque en 24 heures de temps
c'est plus jamais quittée depuis huit
ans
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui ça se dit c'est comme ça
c'est mais vous savez des moments il n'y
a pas besoin de dire les choses on les
pressant on les reçoit et parfaitement
le manque de tolérance des proches à la
limite on peut comprendre les réactions
en belgique est complètement coincé sur
sa propre expérience et qui poussent des
cris toutes les trois minutes en disant
qu'elle aura ça je comprends pas mais
alors pas théorisé est ce que l'amour
les vitraux du traumatisme et b mais
traumatisé pour lui montre on n'a pas
trop balisé pour les autres volets
rouges
j'avais bien alors je ne connais pas la
cible
mais je dis est ce que vous vous êtes
choqués par ce couple donne quoi ouais
carrément ouais voilà ouais pourquoi
pourquoi parce que ben je pourrais pas
mettre ma famille de côté pour une femme
c'est un possible accord mais vous
comprenez leur famille qui décide de
plus les voir ce qu'ils sont ensemble
dit la vérité
franchement si vous étiez les spis si
vous étiez le pis de mireille vous
auriez eu la même réaction
ouais carrément ouais j'aurais dit quoi
je redis buffett avis et puis un
bénévole a annoncé sa mort et fameux
love ça fait ça m'aurait fait mal au
coeur je suis automatiquement repartie
voir ma mère parce que ma mère c'est
bien sûr reste il c'est mon cher c'est
mon sens quoi donc après au fil du temps
j'aurais accepté nommer un moment donné
alors est donc bon vous comprenez le
lard actions de leurs familles
clairement oui pourquoi ce qu'est ce que
c'est ça qu'est ce qui vous choque
bardon est ce qui vous choque parce que
je suis vieille et ça le choc n'en
vienne je dirais pas mâcher ou alors est
alors suivi et valérie mais le problème
j'arrête maman pas ça le problème des
coûts est le problème si seulement ils
ont le droit de semer oui ça te regarde
pas il sait quand j'étais en train de
les juger des données sur la visée si tu
as tout à fait j'aimerais que le
sociologue nous éclaire sur un point
c'est que moi moi je comprends pas la
règle mais c'est pas prévu dans le
conducteur ça il ya quelque chose quand
même quand on est con quand on fait
partie d'une famille et que on a ce
couple heureux devant soi je pense que
ça renvoie des images de la famille pour
le fils par rapport à madame pour les
parents par rapport à monsieur qui
déconstruisent un peu l'image qu'on a de
la famille est ce que c'est ça qui doit
témoigner parce que tout ramener la
coupe à renée le paper board qu'on est
prêt pour marlène schiappa c'est
exactement ça c'est exactement ça basa
bouche même des convenances
alors ok ce que vous dites à lisieux moi
j'ai tellement j'étais comme une maman
c'était une mare envoie la maman maman
peut pas trop l'imaginer après avec
quelques ça ça ça voilà ça ça gêne ça là
j'avais le rôle de maman de mamie et
puis c'est tout où va ce que la mort les
vous parlez de relationnel et c'est
normal ils vous imaginez pas avoir des
relations
on revient à l'intolérance à la sic
oui aujourd'hui on revient à
l'intolérance classique un noir un blanc
parfaitement voilà on leur view mais oui
je vous âgées un plus jeune avec ses
dires a évolué vient de saisir de base
et pour m'avoir l'amour n'a pas d'âge
alors juste la gemmi mohamed dit la
vérité
je sais que vous êtes toujours en est
est ce que vous ce couple vous choque
dit la vérité
écoutez ça qu'on tombe sur mes idées
assez facilement les tous dire qu'il est
choqué il a des propos un peu
caricaturaux je vous la corde
néanmoins parce qu'on est loin d'être
choqués et ce quand la droite d'être
gêné la réponse est oui dit elle mais
est ce qu on doit interdire ce qui est
choquant et ce qui est gênant la réponse
est non donc à partir moment ils font ce
qu'ils veulent
moi j'ai aucun problème pas fait mais on
a le droit d'être dérangés par les
carrés ne pas le comprendre
tout en les tolérant et en acceptant
leur relation donc je pense que
l'histoire est finalement sur la
tolérance
ce que je veux dire c'est monsieur
d'abord d'abord une question qui sait
quel l'argent dans les deux c'est pas
une union des montants plus que c'est
pas une nuit entière c'est pas le coup
d'un soir
ces huit tonnes qui sont justement quand
on sait mais quand on s'est mis en
couple donc relativement vite omet 24
heures on nous donnait pas une semaine
ensemble pour mireille c'était une
passade
alors envie d'aller voir si l'herbe
était d'ailleurs époux calais puis pour
lionel bah c'était comme souvent on me
le fait sur facebook les émoticônes
quand il ya des postes sur la différence
d'âge où des gens jettent les billets
j'aimerais après servir j'ai un ami
j'ai un ami qui avec une jeune fille qui
s'appelle chantal qui a vraiment
nombreuses années puisque lui et on lui
avaient tous dit que les parcs nature
rep ah bah ça fait neuf ans qu'ils sont
ensemble
ben voyons pas la plus dorée cyril total
donc une fois qu'on m'avait dit qu'il
n'y a pas d'enjeu financier matériel
donc c'est bien beau dire
l'effort que vous pouvez vous aimez 5 et
quelque chose d'autre derrière mais moi
la question qu'on doit se poser c'est on
ad on a des codes un peu culturel
mention tous et dans les autres
économies je peux comprendre qu'au
départ je peux comprendre qu'au départ
les parents de commencer des jardins et
lionel de lionel élan est le fils de
mireille de mireille et une réticence
je peux le comprendre on va pas leur
jeter la pierre les blâmer ensuite
normalement un fils qui aime sa mère
des parents qui aiment leur fils s'il
vous voit heureux dans la durée dépassés
ils doivent déposer sa voix par l'amour
qu'ils ont pour vous et me l'a été et le
fait qu'il soit heureux de vous voir
heureux quand on aime les gens on a
envie de les voir heureux
arlette il comprend pas que ça continue
alors alors il mais c'est comme ça
j'aimerais qu'on est on est on à un
nouveau témoignage qu'il ya mélanie
ericsson le public mélanie elle a 22 ans
lassé le contraire mélanie a 22 ans et
éric à 53 ans 31 ans de différence levé
vous mélanie eric mélanie eric qui sont
avec vous alors vous êtes ensemble
depuis trois ans ils vont se pacser
lundi prochain j'ai envie de vous dire
mabrouk annick vous êtes vous êtes
rencontrés parce que mélanie était la
baby sitter du fils d'éric voilà et vous
avez subit aussi le regard des autres de
la famille de mélanie eric vous êtes
fait insulter gravement par votre
famille notamment est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter eric non c'est pas la
famille c'est avec la famille et je vois
là il paraît qu'ils ont pas ils non
c'est un saint voisin qui va traiter de
pédophile alors qu'ils ont passés de
pédophiles alors oui carrément france et
voilà c'est des personnes qui
réfléchissent pas ce qu'ils disent
pour moi c'est franchement ça va pas
choquer quoi venant d'un je tairai pas
de nom parce que moi c'est mon voisin
mais bon avec votre famille ça se passe
même par contre moi j'ai des relations
avec mes cousins et cousines j'ai pas de
souci j'ai une belle fille 42 le fica 23
ans qui donc elle même âge que ma copine
ça se passe
alors c'était la baby sitter de votre
fils et il a cage maintenant mettre son
fils à 13 ans maintenant 13 ans il est
con il est content de votre union bien
sûr il est très content il est très
heureux voilà de vous voir ensemble il
n'y a pas de souci il s'entendit
s'entend très bien comment ça s'est
passé en fait ce que c'est vrai qu'être
les téléspectateurs
nous rejoignent se disent on a tous
envie de savoir comment s'est passé
parce que vous êtes tombé amoureux voilà
où vous en faites à la fin même quand
elle garder votre fils vous restez à la
maison et juste pour l'avoir c'était
comment caen s'est passé non non non non
pas du tout en fait c'est qu'en fait on
est en couple chacun notre côté si
chacun en coupe d'accord d'accord est en
fait voilà les couples à l'est pas des
deux côtés
donc vous avez quitté votre femme pour
pour redon pour mélanie et mélanie vous
avez quitté votre amoureux pour pour
eric c'est ça et vous votre famille et
mélanie komala réagit pas très très bien
enfin venue du mal à accepter au début
mais après ça a été pourquoi au début
vous disais quoi il pensait que ça avait
pas durer c'est surtout pour l'avenir
ouais il avait du mal à voir l'avenir
vous voulez des enfants plus tard mari
et vous croyez que monsieur va pouvoir
vous en donner oui bah il a 53 ans n'est
pas non plus ah ouais mais à un moment
donné
[Rires]
le moment donné le petit bisou il va
plus là bas il va pas au fond n'est pas
séché les cours de sciences nat
[Applaudissements]
là vous êtes choqués franchement je suis
plus choqué pour la jeune fille parce
qu'elle va vouloir des enfants plus tard
la pêche alors est ce que vous savez
vous à venir comme pour projet d'avoir
peut-être des enfants tous les deux sur
voilà et ça me dérange pas du tout la
différence d'âge mélanie pollue pas du
tout alors mais vous pouvez encore en
faire vous vous avez quel âge as tu bien
non mais devient une obsession la sirène
vous plaît c'est comme pour lionel et
mignolet vous pardon lyonnais j'avais
des envies et quatre enfants et je ne
souhaite plus au nord ouais après c'est
dans ces cas là je peux comprendre et
vous acceptez myriam immédiatement oui à
la plage mais ressent au 30 13 et 17 ans
et sont tous ont manigancé leur maman sa
soeur deuxième maman qu'on voit là on
peut ça c'est leur belle maman c'est sa
rue marion progresse il a dit je peux
comprendre et c'est déjà des combats on
se pose par miss cougar jane est ce que
c'est votre stylo mais je dis que c'est
réciproque l'homme
c'est pour les cils mac
quoi qu'est ce qui se passe ou la
cisaille pas nous faire elle va nous
faire une mylène farmer non mais je vais
aller le remercier j'ai vu pareil on m'a
dit la production m'a dit vous êtes vous
aviez bien aimé vous aimez bien eric
naulleau il ya quelqu'un du public
on m'a dit oui
ah oui il ya eu des des fuites je ne
sais pas si j'ai froid il me propose sa
chemise alors voilà ça j'aime pas ça va
c'est pas miss cougar ces bons ni eric
naulleau nom mérite donc la veille à
pailles appâtant différents chemise il
n'est pas dans mon lit un oui mais ça si
je prends sa chemise bah c'est et il
fait quoi il restaure ce n'est pas mon
âge ce serait pas prudent et sait pas on
est bien conservée ou s'il vous plaît
alors alors non mais là ça vous choque
pas eric naulleau non franchement bon
bah non il a un peu des cheveux blancs
donc ça va ça presse accorde ou non mais
c'est bizarre mais aussi les gens les
gens qui ont d'énormes comme ça lors
eric nom des normes avec des limites
six mois de plus c'est bon ça pose là je
suis pas l'esprit quand je veux je
fonctionne pas du tout sur ce mode de
jeu ça me fascine toujours les gens qui
ont des limites dans leur tête tellement
étroites en faire beaucoup de personnes
pensent comme lui moi je pense à à
mélanie laurent qui se sont mis debout
tout à l'heure oui j'imagine la
difficulté eric pardon la difficulté
qu'ils ont encore à eric de la
commission qu'ils ont dû nommer subie
face déjà c'est un couple mixte
oui déjà la mélanie elle a 22 ans elle
en fait 15 à ton avantage ans la belle
hein parce que les belles et tout mais
voilà tu fais beaucoup plus jeune donc
j'imagine que ça a dû être extrêmement
difficile pour vous et c'est vrai que
tout de suite on se dit tout de suite
voilà que c'est plus un intérêt comment
la minute alors que c'est pour de
l'argent c'est parce qu'il a ceci parce
qu'il à cela alors que même lorsque les
gens ont parfois le même âge
il se marie aussi ou bien son nom
parfois pour des intérêts alors on l'a
dit pas suffisamment sa gâteau pour l'ap
hm tendue sur ce qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
ah ben moi je suis pour l'amour quel
qu'il soit donc moi je suis très
heureuse pour jouer vous êtes choqués
par les propos de mejdi je suis amusé
par les propos de me dit je suis pas
choqué mais c'est vrai que tu fais
preuve d'un peu de de fermeture d'esprit
surtout que ton anecdote elle était elle
était assez marrante mais bon c'est que
tu la voulais aussi n'avait pas l'air
d'être non pupitre à et le produit sous
la gorge
voilà je pense quoi mais agathe tout ça
tout ça vous dérange pas voilà du tout
et j'espère qu'eric va donner sa chemise
art sauf que c'est un défi à relever
alors c'est quoi le défi relevé lui
enlever sa chemise
les pictogrammes one mais je suis
harcelé ce qu'il a mais je n'ai pas
moins de 18 mètres le pictogramme moins
de 18 ans
alors bernard laporte n'a pas trop plein
de vertus non non mais moi je suis je
dit exactement ce que la majorité au dc
ils sont heureux
il faut avoir une liberté d'une
ouverture d'esprit parce qu'ils fassent
qu'encore une fois il ya qu un tout qui
compte c'est que soient heureux de vivre
ce qu'il vit le point dali et je trouve
rétrograde
votre fils mireille ou légendes de huy
de leurs amis de monsieur madame
derrière qui de suite ce but se ferme et
ses pieds au départ effectivement pas de
la gare se mêlent delachaux prise de
l'étonnement puis quand tu vois qu'on
nous demande tout se passait bien
bravo maman est heureuse papa est
heureux ma soeur est heureusement très
tôt il ya que ça qui compte
alors mesdames on entend les efforts et
ces sites étaient proposés sur 1600 par
les communes s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît le couple le couple dont on parle
le plus mine de rien c'est que l'on
écoute présidentielle ce qu'il ya plein
de couple voilà j'ai au point
d'injection nathalie aussi qu avec et
nathalie elle est très bien pour son
agent qui sait vivian nathalie ah oui
mais ça c'est des gros lol pourquoi
merci on n'a pas les mêmes de référence
ne sais pas
quand emmanuel macron est devenu
président il y avait 20 et 24 ans qui
sépare de sa femme brigitte ont beaucoup
choqué vous le savez lors d'une
conférence de presse le président était
revenue sur les rumeurs d'homosexualité
à son égard pu avait évoqué le sujet de
la différence d'âge avec sa femme qui
soulevait de nombreuses remarques
sexistes et vous allez donner des votes
ramenant sinon je vais finir expulsés
moi j'allais donner votre avis quand
même regarder on disait dans les dîners
parisiens que j'étais homosexuel que je
vivais entre autres avec mathieu gallet
m'enfin on a peut-être été d'autres
votre vie parallèle c'est assez
déplaisant quand ça n'est pas le cas ça
dit trois choses 1 une dégradation
profonde des moeurs politiques
deuxième chose c'est que ça en dit long
sur l'homophobie rampante et la
troisième c'est que ça en dit beaucoup
sur la misogynie rampant exactement est
ce que si j'avais eu 20 ans de plus que
mon épouse personne n'aurait pensé une
seule seconde que je pouvais être en
couple illégitime c'est parce qu'elle a
vingt ans de plus que moi que beaucoup
disaient ce truc n'est pas tenable c'est
impossible
donc en fait c'est tu dis simplement que
ces gens là ont un grand problème avec
les représentations sociales et la place
de la femme alors vous avez vu en quoi
alors sur le mandat ce qui a je
comprends plus en clair bon alors la com
com com comme quoi vous comprenez palace
qui comprend pas il dit qu'en fait si
j'avais été le contraire tout alors
bastien mais je dis est ce que tu es
choqué franchement oui un petit peu
quand ils sont arrivés en 2010 cette
main dans la main ouais ça m'a choqué
vous avez dit quoi bof
ouais ouais ça vous ça vous a plu ben je
me suis va pas tarder à partir sa vie la
série buffy ni l'expulser mois après
mois quel âge ma maman elle a 43 ans
d'accord évalue votre papa mon papa il a
44 ans maintenant mais il est décédé
d'accord oui non mais il avait un angle
différent pas de talent mais alors non
mais ne pouvait pas dire c'est
maintenant aujourd'hui il ya des gens
aujourd'hui en plus il ya un truc qui se
passe c'est que les gens de 60 ans de 50
ans de 70 ans sont plus du tout les
mêmes en fer qui a acquis à 30 ans c'est
vrai que ça n'a rien à voir je pense que
maintenant il ya une différence en fait
de dix ans vous enlevez disant à chaque
en plus - quote je crois par exemple
chez brigitte mac os
à quel âge 75 mais non 65 ans comme vous
à la 60 pas choisir je préférerais bien
comme vous regardez vous yahya yahya
yann moix qui avait exprimé son
impossibilité à aimer une femme de plus
de 50 ans il disait dans une interview
je suis au psg je vous dis la vérité à
50 ans je suis incapable d'aimer une
femme de 50 ans ça ce n'est pas possible
je trouve ça trop vieux je préfère le
corps des femmes jeunes c'est tout un
corps de femme de 25 ans est
extraordinaire le corps de femme de 50
ans n'est pas extraordinaire du tout il
s'est ensuite expliqué regarder et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis bien entendu
la turia je préfère le corps des femmes
jeunes c'est tout point
je ne vais pas vous mentir un corps de
femme de 25 ans est extraordinaire le
corps d'une femme de 50 ans n'est pas
extraordinaire il assume
regardez c'était hier soir sur rtl avec
marc olivier fogiel on n'est pas
responsable ni de ses goûts ni de ses
penchants y de ses inclinations les
cougars sont à la mode
je me considère pas comme un puma ces
passages chaque individu est prisonnier
et donc de ses acquis nationaux et des
propos que je ne regrette pas parce
qu'ils ne regardent que moi et j'aime
qui je veux et je n'ai pas à répondre au
tribunal du goût qui pour moi une
absence totale de goût à braga il ya une
dame capio 10e
voilà alors bâti on peut lui donner le
micro la dame souple et vite vite vite
vite plus vite merci si mokhtar
belmokhtar alors il a le courage levé
vous levez vous et moi vous exprimer son
opinion et tout le monde doit le
respecter
hier alors qu'ils me pas les fraises qui
n'est pas le chocolat je n'aime pas ça
pourquoi pas d'accord alors zoppi libre
et il a de quoi je te le dire c'est pas
forcément je suis féministe
oui j'approuve pas mais c'est un homme
courageux d'accord bas alors on le dit
voilà donc oui et c'est parce qu'on
avait dit surpris dit ce qu'il veut
c'est son droit
vous qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de ce qui vient de dire yann moix
moi oui oui mais une france qui veut
comme moi je fais ce que je veux
donc maintenant il faut demander aussi à
une femme de 25 ans si elle aime son
corps aussi à lui
d'accord alors on a on à l'exo on a
notre on a un autre exemple on s'est dit
allez met son argent oui c'est quoi
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont plutôt aimé son
argent enfin il faut respecter ce qu'ils
y effectivement je sais pas si c'est du
courage
oui bon déjeuner mais elle a le mérite
d'être honnête
exactement gilles pascal et à mieux vous
fait mousser sciemment il a le droit de
donner à tous vas y est tombé dessus et
cetera et cetera
ça semblait pas méchant au départ comme
il le dit c'est ségou shakespeare au
sein des responsables de ces chevaux je
pense pas que je suis mi temps je pense
pas comme lui mais j'accepte que c'était
juste un exemple jours et vous donnera
des couples plus les plus médiatisés du
moment qui attise le plus de haine sur
les réseaux sociaux et un déferlement de
haine sur vincent cassel et tina sa
compagne ils ont trente deux ans de
différence
cinquante deux ans pour vincent cassel
et tina à 21 ans qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
sabu oh mon dieu quoi mon dieu un pas
mon dieu que vous en pensez quoi vous
m'aider eh ben c'est dommage pour elle
en pourquoi dans dix ans agréé avec lui
gesca dans quoi dans le 10 ans espagnol
anglais dans dix ans il peut de ce monde
là mais non il aura que ce sont deux ans
il sera octroyé la moyenne d'âge une
baisse non non rien dans nos séances
vidéo en espérant le vix monde se tait
avait raté les cons l'éducation et
éducation mais simplement un peu con
mais je dis
non non non
l'espérance de vie baisse savent pas
vraiment quoi arrange de vie augmente
oui mais bon c'est moi je voyage pas
cher tn mois tous les matches les pales
je suis fan elle arrête d'augmenter
l'espérance de vie mère savait a
justement là-dessus dites nous à la
règle est d'augmenter l'espérance de vie
stéphane hains c'est vrai ah ouais enfin
jouer perso sur la quantitatif mais oui
l'expérience de vie à arrêter
d'augmenter en europe du sud notamment à
cause de plein de choses très chiante à
raconter qu'on va pas afin qu'ils sont
pas dans le sujet oui et qui sont plutôt
dans les sujets que très d'habitude
monsieur naulleau mais il fallait
pertinemment qu'en grèce elles baissent
c'est qu'au portugal elle stagne en
italie elles stagné qu'en france
également voilà beaucoup n'ont pas le
débat c'est terrible sur le combi
beaucoup qu'on vient de voir très bon
alors voilà
elle est belle elle est très très belle
ya là deux comme je dis encore le côté
ou mixtes et en plus ya l'âge il ya
trois raisons trois critères qui font
qu'ils cristallisent la méchanceté va à
la jalousie des oeufs
après c'est leur histoire c'est leur
problème c'est leur amour
c'est leur vie c'est leur choix et c'est
à eux de décider pourquoi un kiss in
book ce serait plus beau qu'un autre ce
que ça vous fait du couple mixte
non non non je le vois bien je crois
deviner mais j'avais une fille peut
maintenant je fais pas le coup du couple
mixte jeudi jusqu'au lorsque alors vous
été fasciné par leur couple ne s'était
déchaîné pouvait pas tolérer des couples
mixtes le connaît bien les couples
mixtes puisque à priori je jamais déjà
qu'on découpe le mix on doit déjà faire
face à d en effet en 1950 année en 2010
des chanteurs les couples mixtes c'est
presque les couples de même monsieur je
suis d'accord avec vous je vous dis ce
que les gens supportent sûr que les gens
subissent
on peut demander à mélanie et eric s'ils
sont là alors si jamais la guerre et qui
a justement ne sait
ça rajoute pas perdre ça fait une
accroche est ce qu est ce que vous avez
été victime voilà vous vous de ce que
dit et qui n'auraient seuil et de
racisme oui voilà
il a volé papier voilà voilà elle avait
dépassé valor voilà donc pourquoi est-ce
que je vais rencontrer quand on cible
ensemble j'étais au chômage
d'accord mais pas ensemble pour l'argent
voilà peut-être donc on l'a fait mieux
comme sociologue ou parce qu'elle a
entendu une fois dans sa vie que vous
branchez sur les réseaux sociaux voyez
bien que le racisme est très
décontractée et qu'un comique parce que
je vous avec une différence d'âge c'est
la double peine
exor aux critiques la différence d'âge
et on critique la différence de poids
s'est vraiment évident c'est là c'est
malheureusement regrette mais son élan
alors vous avez donc été victime de
racisme aussi voilà donc c'est sûr
estime voilà vous avez vous avez bien
fait de le souligner et c'est vrai que
sur les réseaux sociaux il ya un
déferlement de haine sur le couple
autres vincent cassel et sa compagne
voilà alors on va vous a demandé à vous
aussi ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
êtes choqués par la différence d'âge on
va voir tout de suite oui ratu pour
attendre non à 72%
donc voila voila préciser une chose
quand même parce qu'on parle de l'âge à
a1 focalisant sur le corps mais est-ce
qu'on peut aussi dire que on al'âge de
son mental at il eu à un moment donné tu
peux avoir deux personnes du même âge
il y en a un qui qui qui mentalement il
a 30 ans de plus qu'il est complètement
décalage et puis tiens une personne qui
peut avoir 20 ans de plus que toi et à
paraître totalement plus jeunes dans ses
choix de vie dans sa manière de le
croquer la vie fait ça existe ça aussi
on ne vit pas qu'avec un corps on vit
aussi avec un être qui a un mental moi
j'ai un kid engagent parfois sur exemple
j'ai encore d'avec de 92 ans et le
mental d'un mec de 12 salles exposé
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est passé
par la chicotte tu as raison